i have not talked about this story too
much because it's sort of tabloid trash
and the dissolution of a celebrity
marriage is neither particularly notable
news nor really any of my business or
interest
but i'll tell you
i i was really hoping those two kids
would make it
i was i know i know it's weird because
you know kim kardashian is a reality tv
porn star and she got her start on this
porn tape and kanye west is one of the
most eccentric
rappers and individuals in the entire
world but i just kind of i kind of
thought i was hoping they would make it
yeah and kanye west he had this
conversion experience
he became quite serious ostensibly about
his christianity and i just thought i
thought it'd be really good if they
could make it
but kim kardashian has said she's chosen
herself there's a seven bazillion word
profile of her now in one of the
magazines what is it vogue i guess
and in it she says i've chosen myself
quote for so long
i did what made other people happy the
41 year old explains and i think in the
last two years i decided i'm going to
make myself happy and that feels really
good and even if that created changes
and caused my divorce i think it's
important to be honest with yourself
about what really makes you happy i've
chosen myself i think it's okay to
choose you she pauses before elaborating
my 40s are about being team me i'm going
to eat well i'm going to work out i'm
going to have more fun spend more time
with my kids and the people who make me
happy i'm going to put my phone down
it's just it's about me
and it yeah maybe that's going to cause
the dissolution of my marriage and yeah
maybe that's going to traumatize my
children and yeah maybe that's going to
cause just horrible problems for
everyone who i ostensibly love but you
know
i just kind of wanna i just kind of
wanna and that's really good and
important right be selfish it's really
good to be selfish so says the moral
philosopher kim kardashian
she has no right to do this this is
horribly reckless this is terrible for
her children it's wrong to do this in
her marriage it's just wrong it's just
wrong everything about it is wrong and i
bring it up not just to shame kim
kardashian but because so many people
believe this in our culture they just
think i've got i'm so put upon i do so
much for everybody else what are you
talking about lady you are a celebrity a
reality tv star celebrity your your
entire career is about being
self-obsessed and so you've been
self-obsessed for your whole life and
now you're being more self-obsessed and
you're pretending that that's a change
which it's not and you're pretending
it's a change for the better which it
wouldn't be even if it were true
it's you're just doing more of what
you've been doing the whole time and
it's leading you to ever more
destructive
ever more destructive behaviors
so this is a great way to live a
miserable life
i'm i'm very sad that kim yay seems to
be splitting up but let this be
a cautionary tale in the year of our
lord 2022 why are you going to the brick
and mortar auto parts store why are you
taking the time to get in your car drive
the 15 minutes go and wait online go
talk to the guy get peppered with
questions he goes in the back to look
for the part that you want for your car
or truck they don't have it he comes
back he says we're gonna have to order
it come back in two weeks you drive home
you god why why
gosh why are you doing that when you
could go to rock rockauto.com
right now family business they got all
the parts for your car truck that you
could possibly want you could save 30
you could save 50
off the part the very same part that you
get in the brick and mortar store you
get it the website is so easy to
navigate even i can do it no gimmicks
it's not that you got to log in tuesday
morning at 11 a.m to save 15 notes
always reliably low prices same prices
for pros and do-it-yourselfers go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you i'm glad
you liked that clip ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you